he's such a whiner they do nice ok yeah
there is one okay as we're all like
peering in his life to feel free to free
ball John is getting a little hot out
there huh
it's beach time well there's five
specific things everyone should know
about so five essential essentials so
Garrett there's this guy standing next
to me this is our three the model
obviously he looks great in each one but
the DVDs suits will work for anyone
first one we have here's the retro it
has these kind of classic menswear
elements that you would normally see on
like a tailored short extended waist tab
you see here the side tabs I tend to
keep it tight they're a little bit
slimmer a little bit shorter they have
this kind of like old-school quality to
them any store chances are they'll have
something like this that will look great
on you these are our what we called the
runner in fact you could actually
probably work out in these to go running
go right into the beach or the pool as
I'm looking at this it looks like a
short short I mean it is shorter because
it has that kind of whole school running
athletic vibe to it one of the big
things is the piping it's usually in a
contrast color and also the side slit
just a classic running short detail
these have an elastic waist easy pull on
pull off
stretch up we would say probably buy
them in a bright kind of pop color
they're just like a really cool
versatile short that you can kind of
wear all summer long
if you're going to one place go to Zara
because they have awesome swimwear
really in expensive a little bit shorter
than usual they are shorter I mean this
is the same kind of vibe as the runner
short we call it the boxer because it
has that vibe of like a traditional
boxer short at home I have a few boxers
that are sitting in my drawer that are
long and baggy not looking like this
clean it up
flattering that's a lot of gray you can
see this print to the print is a larger
scale you want to go for a larger scale
pattern because it's just multiple
Tamila more flattering yeah very
slimming from the top so we call these
the convertible short they're made to
kind of go from the pool dip or the
beach to the bar or the restaurant to
walk around and they look just like
normal so this is a great short to pack
new suit kiss when you're going on -
absolutely you don't even have to be
going to the beach - you know to where
these are out the thing that makes them
more like quoting quick normal shorts is
this kind of fixed waistband these are
from Borla Bar Brown who basically
invented this idea
they're super flattering and with this
color blocking thing it's a cool kind of
up due to the scale I think every guy
knows these I think every guy probably
has a pair of in his closet
the modern update to this classic surf
Jam is that snap front instead of the
lace that you would normally think of
and also these are on a little bit of
the shorter side you'll notice that
they're not to your V if it's lower than
two inches above your your knee the nuts
too long the side panels super
flattering any sort of like wider hip
the girth I if you're a little
self-conscious about that area it'll
really slim it down it'll look great on
basically anyone are you guys that's a
wrap you heard it from us at GQ the five
essential swimsuits for summer if you
have any questions leave them in the
comments below and have the most stylish
summer ever
yes